Nura rise of the yokai clan yeah I
haven't seen it yet and it was something
that she was watching and she wanted the
official blu-rays and not like the
bootleg so and that is why I don't film
in the basement too much my god it sound
like someone's being murdered and a dog
at the same time what's up guys I'm
currently in my basement I have talked
for many years about doing an anime
collection video every time I do a
blu-ray collection update video people
always ask me to show my anime blu-rays
and I'm going to show you my anime
blu-rays and my anime DVDs my full
complete collection of anime and I keep
it in my basement where every anime fan
should keep their collection because it
just makes sense so I'm going to show
you all my anime blu-rays first and then
we'll do the DVDs last I'm not going to
give you in-depth amazing thoughts on
all these titles because we'd be here
forever let's get going the first is a
comic got killed this show was on
Toonami as you can see I've seen the
entirety of this blu-ray but not
obviously this one because I haven't
opened it yet it's a fun enjoyable show
but unfortunately somewhat forgettable
which is why I haven't finished it yet
no anime collection is complete without
Akira or Akira or wherever you want to
say apparently it's kind of up to you
from what I understand but this is a
fantastic film that I hope to review one
day in-depth angel's egg this movie was
directed by Mamoru Oshii this is an
incredible film if you've never seen
angels egg I highly recommend checking
it out I'm actually working on an
in-depth analysis of this film because I
really enjoy doing my analysis of stay
which was an older film and I liked the
idea of doing an analysis of a movie
that was older and I could explore it
more and maybe this film isn't talked
about enough I really think that it
should be if you've never seen angels
egg check it out and doing a big
analysis of it very soon
the Animatrix the companion piece to the
Matrix films this is a whole bunch of
short films some of them are great some
of them are not so great some of them
are kind of bad and I might be talking
about this soon another is an anime show
that I've actually not seen yet I
haven't watched it yet but I'm excited
to hey I finally get to talk about
attack on Titan my longtime viewers
knows this sort of a thing I kept saying
I'm going to talk about attack on Titan
and I never did because I'm a lazy
bastard look I have not finished this
show yet I'm going to be completely
honest I've seen a lot of the first part
I don't love it the same way everyone
else loves it I think it's good and
enjoyable and entertaining but I have a
hard time getting into the characters
and I'm sure that if I watch the rest of
the show like I should then I probably
would enjoy it more obviously I like it
enough to keep it and I'm excited to see
the rest at some point but that's why I
never got around to reviewing because I
kept like watching all of it I got close
to watching all of it I mean and then
I'd be and something would get in the
way and then it would just become a
thing where it never got completed
Bayonetta bloody fate this is a very
dumb movie but it's dumb in all the
right ways trust me if you're a fan of
the games especially belladonna of
sadness is a blu-ray that was recently
released to kind of restore this film
that's a very unknown Japanese movie
from the 70s that I have yet to see I
picked it up because I was excited to
see it and we'll see how it is when I do
watch it the berserk collection the
newer ones these were actually sent to
me in my p.o box and again I have yet to
watch them but I'm excited to thank you
by the way to the viewer who sent these
to me I am constantly floored and blown
away by how amazing you guys are and I
greatly appreciate it it really means a
lot to me that you guys care thank you
now as you may know my wife is also a
big anime fan so some of the things in
this collection are actually hers or
titles that I've bought for her or that
she had and then we just kind of
combined our collections and one of the
things that's hers is the black butler
series and OVA is I believe I haven't
seen this yet that's why I don't know
but this is a Sam thing and she hasn't
watched to yet it's not open you know
what one's not even open my gosh she was
watching it on Netflix I think and we
ended up picking up the blu-rays because
I think they were on sale Black Lagoon
and Black Lagoon
Roberta's blood trail these are real
the fun action animes I haven't watched
this yet if I'm being honest but the
show is really really fun a lot of
really fun action very badass blue
submarine number six was on Toonami back
in the day this was a like a six part
thing a four part thing and it was aired
it aired on Toonami I remember watching
and being like this is so cool it was
like a special Toonami thing and when
they released on blu-ray obviously I had
to pick it up the boy and the beast as
you guys know is one of my favorite
movies of 2016 I think it's incredible
directed by Mamoru Hosoda if you have
not seen it yet please do it's one of
the best of last year and one of my
favorite anime movies of all time first
angel the first of my incredible fan
service
stupid dumb cheesy guilty pleasure
tongue-in-cheek anime that I don't care
and sometimes I enjoy watching Real Talk
here this is one of the first things I
ever watched in a new apartment when I
was younger I moved into a new place
with my parents and to kind of get
myself feeling you know used to being
there I was like I'm just gonna watch
something fun and I watched this I still
remember that being one of the first
times I've started getting used to my
new apartment because I hate moving and
I was like okay you know what maybe I
feel okay by this new place now because
this was so stupid and dumb and it made
me laugh you know and ever since then
it's had a soft spot in my heart
Cardcaptor Sakura or Cardcaptor Sakura
this is something I bought for my wife
that she has yet to watch as you can see
this was a show that she really liked
back in a day and this is the movie and
you know what if I'm being honest I
kinda like the show back in the big two
castle in the sky the first of my studio
ghibli collection I just want to say
there's something I'm very proud of I
have every slipcover for every studio
ghibli blu-ray that I have and that was
something that was hard to do but I just
I needed it I needed it to happen and I
did it so yeah
collector Lupin the third the castle of
Cagliostro was the first film directed
by Hayao Miyazaki I believe and it's a
lot of fun especially if you like the
loop on the third show the cat returns
the unofficial sequel of sorts to the
whisper of the heart not as good as the
whisper of the heart but still a lot of
fun children who chase lost voices this
has another title in some other places
it's like The Journey
have something I forget it's directed by
Makoto Shinkai the guy who made your
name which was another one of my
favorite films of 2016 Claymore now I
got to be honest I have not yet seen
this I picked this up entirely because
of a hard core recommendation from a fan
I saw that a fan was really telling me I
should check this out and that they
thought I would really like it and if
you're still watching my videos thanks
for telling me that man because I did
buy it entirely because of you I have
yet to watch it though but I will one
day
definitely the cowboy bebop collection
of course as you know this is my
favorite anime of all time I think it
kind of goes back and forth between this
and DBZ but I'm pretty sure Cowboy Bebop
is my favorite because I love DBZ
bullets face it cowboy bebop is just
quality and Dragon Ball Z is like
amazing garbage I love it I mean it
seriously some episodes really suck
there's no sucky episodes in the show
and I just recently picked up the Amazon
exclusive because it went on sale around
Black Friday finally for a reasonable
price of like 60 bucks it was like 150
to 200 dollars before that even more
expensive than that and I was like no
I'm not going to do that but they
finally released it for a good price so
pick both of those up and the Cowboy
Bebop movie which is fantastic a little
too long has a little bit too much
talkie talkie but it's a lot of fun and
really well animated and of course the
music is amazing Death Note the complete
series this is a fantastic show right up
until a certain choice is made in the
storyline if you guys have watched the
show you probably know exactly what I'm
talking about something they do with a
character that just takes the entire
show in a terrible direction and I've
it's like one of those things where
you're just watching it and you keep
thinking to yourself what the hell were
they thinking why did they do that you
you had gold and you just turned it into
bronze or something you know it was just
like it was I don't know it's good
though it's definitely worth watching
death parade is a newer release I have
not yet watched I picked this up I want
to see it I like stuff by madhouse this
is madhouse right yeah madhouse and I
like horror scary anime and I'm hoping
this is pretty good but I haven't seen
it yet now I'm not going to show you
guys all of these but I do have Dragon
Ball Z season 1 through 9 and the two
films that have been released
Eden of the East is another title that I
picked up based off of recommendations
and I have not yet seen it but I will
soon elfin
I hope I said that right elfin lead I'm
not sure this is one of the most bloody
like disturbing boobies animes like ever
ha ha if that description didn't win
your heart then I don't know what else
to say
ergo proxy Ergo Proxy I sometimes I
don't understand how to pronounce the
animes that I own
I haven't yet finished all of this FLCL
or fully coolly is an anime classic it's
so weird and so strange it's very short
it was on Adult Swim in the past and I
remember watching it not really
understanding it but being mesmerized by
it because the animation is so
spectacular in the music and it's such a
strange vision from up on poppy Hill is
a Studio Ghibli film that I have yet to
see I am cherishing being able to see
Studio Ghibli films I've never seen
there's a couple I haven't seen I do
have a slipcover for this which is hard
to find I have the full metal alchemist
complete series and the incredibly rare
part one of brotherhood which is now out
of print I don't have part two but the
finding this in a star was like oh my
god there it is the garden of words is a
beautiful very short film it's not even
really feature-length it's like 40
minutes or something but it's directed
by Makoto Shinkai of your name and
children who chase lost voices Fame
ghost in the shell' another film like
Acura that you just have to have if this
video goes live before the new film is
Scarlett Johansson I am reviewing all
the ghost in the shell' movies before
that and I'm excited to do that
this is currently the rarest blu-ray
that I own ghost in the shell' - in a
sense the Bandai version with the
English dub and the Japanese language
with good English subtitles not like the
first release this is out of print and
incredibly rare and I did pay a little
too much for it but I just I couldn't
watch that movie on that shitty American
DVD that was released and I did track
this down and it's it's the rarest thing
I own as of now unless they you know put
it back out into print and ghost in the
shell' solid state society which I'm
also going to be reviewing before the
new ghost in the shell' film in March
and I have the to ghost in the shell'
arrise collections this show left me a
little bit cold
did the film which I did review on my
channel I picked it up specifically
because I'm such a ghost in the shell'
completionist and I didn't hate it and I
wanted to give it a second chance now
here's the major collector in me I have
the girl who lived through time one of
Mamoru hosted as best films I have
that's the the collector's edition I
have the normal standard version and
before that I did buy the extremely rare
again Bandai out of print version and of
course right when I buy this literally
like I'm not even kidding
I bought this it was too expensive no
joke like two weeks later they're like
hey we're really sing at Funimation got
the rights to it and I wanted to just
take my head and rip it off and throw it
off of a high structure uh-huh
nevertheless my completionist in me is
kind of happy that I have it this is
another one of my wife's a good
librarian like a Good Shepherd she
wanted to see it she hasn't seen it yet
I bought it for her because you know I
like being a good guy I try to be a good
guy anyway uh great with a Firefly so oh
my god if you've never seen this this is
intense
really dark depressing but it's one of
those movies that you kind of have to
see at some point here's another one of
my wife's goo goo ray Co Clarice on ya
Gunn bustard the movie I haven't seen it
yet obviously at least this I haven't
seen I bought this because back in the
day I remember liking Gunbuster and
apparently this is heavily edited and
trimmed and censored which is kind of
disappointing Howl's Moving Castle
amazing film when a Studio Ghibli's best
Hyperdimension Neptunia because why the
hell not I mean I need I need cheesy
anomie sometimes in my life I'm not
gonna apologize for it
I need stupid dumb and everyone needs
like a dumb movie or piece of
entertainment
come exceeds like that kind of trashy
entertainment they're ok with and for me
it's silly fanservice anime and I enjoy
watching it from time to time I have two
Inuyasha
things I have Inuyasha the final act and
the complete collection of the movies
Inuyasha is a lot of fun my wife likes
it more than I do I haven't seen all of
it the episodes that I have
I've really enjoyed though Jinro the
wolf Brigade this was written by Mamoru
Oshii
and this is a bloody violent movie but
it is worth seeing if you're an anime
fan kids on the slope is directed by
Shinichiro Watanabe of Cowboy Bebop Fame
and I did review this actually there's a
review for this on my channel if you
want to check it out
you can learn more about it there Kiki's
Delivery Service is so great I love this
movie another Studio Ghibli this is a
really beautiful film a letter to Momo I
bought because I heard it was really
good and I have yet to see it and I'm
excited to do that
once again cheesy fanservice anime that
I am NOT going to apologize for owning
Lord marksman and Vanna dis Michiko and
Hodgkin I first heard of from toonami
and eventually I picked this up the save
super amazing value edition My Neighbor
Totoro childhood classic Nausicaa of the
valley of the wind I wish it was just
called like Nausicaa that would be
better but the night of the Galactic
railroad is another film I have not yet
seen I picked it up because I want to
see it ninja scroller as I call it blood
and boobs boobs boobs boobs blood boobs
boobs boobs boobs I talked about that in
my japanimation era retro rewind noir
this is very cool it has an ending
that's a little in it's a little whimper
II you know it's kinda like I kind of
went out with a whimper instead of a
bang but I enjoy the journey not so much
the destination of this anime Nura rise
of the yokai clan where was I had these
are my wife's I bought them for her
because she was interested in the show
she watched some episodes online I'm not
sure what platform Hulu crunchyroll
something like that and she wanted the
show so I bought it for only yesterday a
really gorgeous Studio Ghibli film
finally officially released in America
it wasn't released for the longest time
because Disney didn't like that some of
the girls talked about basically
reaching puberty and I was like really
come on but finally we got the official
release of it thanks to G kids paprika
a film by Satoshi Kon this is very much
so like Inception should I say inception
is kind of like this parasite was a show
that I also started watching on Toonami
and I haven't watched the actual
blu-rays of them yet but I really liked
what I saw on Toonami which is
I picked them up Patlabor 1 & 2 both
films directed by Mamoru Oshii really
fun robot gundam mecha style animes
accepts the focus isn't on the mechs and
the action it's a they're both very
human movies which is really cool and
you got to have some cheesiness as I've
said I got the Pokemon collection 1 2 &
3 the steelbook and these 4 pokemon
films which I have not opened yet
pom Paco is a Studio Ghibli film I have
yet to see but it was cool when they
announced that would be on blu-ray
Ponyo which I am very curious to know if
any of my viewers today are still with
me since this review because Ponyo was
actually my very first review on my old
channel and i remember that that was
when it was quick movie reviews and it
was literally like a minute and 13
seconds long or something I think that
was the exact run time my whole goal was
I was going to make really short movie
reviews and I eventually went away from
that because I like to talk in depth
about film next we have Porco Rosso
another Studio Ghibli film that I'm
excited to see and Princess Mononoke
which is one of my favorites I'm not
going to show you all seven volumes but
I do have Ranma 1/2 the complete show on
blu-ray
that's one of my wife's favorite shows
and I've watched a lot of it with her
and it's a ton of fun if you've never
seen Ranma 1/2 it's a very cool gender
body-swapping type anime it's a lot of
fun really funny really cool action it's
one of those enemies that should have
been on Toonami but probably wasn't
because of the gender swapping thing and
all the nudity there's a lot of boobs
royal space force the wings of hominis
Amun and these some don't know how to
say that I'm really super excited to
watch this this I just got this
yesterday in the mail and I'm really
super pumped to watch this because a lot
of people view this as one of the first
anime films that really inspired anime
movies to be more realistic in nature
like Akira and ghosts in the show
samurai seven kind of one of those
essential titles beautifully animated
show samurai Champloo Shinichiro
Watanabe foray into the samurai action
world and
it is awesome The Secret World of
Arrietty another Studio Ghibli film
beautiful movie serial experiments lain
the complete show this is one weird
anime it's very rewarding though if you
like cerebral horrific science anime I
don't even really know how to explain it
actually it's very unique and there's
nothing else like this short piece a
collection of animated short films
highly suggest checking this out it's
very artistic the sky crawlers another
Mamoru Oshii film definitely one of his
worst not one of his better films but I
wouldn't describe this as a bad movie
but uh it's it's it's lacking I own it
because I'm a completionist and I don't
hate it
but it could be a lot better Snow White
and the red hair is a title I bought for
my wife recently that she has yet to
watch a lot of these things I buy for
her she has yet to watch but hopefully
she will one day space dandy this is a
really fun show haven't seen all of it
yet but what I have seen I really like
it was on Toonami and that's what
introduced me to it in Italy spirited
away do I even have to say anything it's
one of the best animated films of all
time I think it's one of the best movies
ever made not just animated but it's
incredible definitely see this movie if
you haven't if you haven't I actually
really envy you because you get to watch
this for the first time steins gate this
is a very cool show the animation is
really good I liked the time jumping
aspect of it it's very unique
check it out never seen it Street
Fighter 2 the animated movie I haven't
opened this yet but I've seen it back in
the day and yeah this is just one of
those movies that you kind of have to
have here around my age it's one of
those nostalgic movies if you grew up
with this kind of stuff it means
something to you and this movie means
something to me and I was so happy when
they released it on blu-ray I have two
versions of summer Wars another mammarra
hosted a film I have the one that was
out for a long time in the most recent
collection that was released to be sort
of in line with the girl who left
through time collection they're working
on now at Funimation this movie is great
it's not his best but it's really worth
checking out sort of the stranger
another one of those Bandai blu-rays
this one isn't too rare though too
knowledge tales from Earthsea I'll be
honest haven't seen this one yet largely
because a lot of people have said it's
not that great but I will watch it since
I'm a studio ghibli completionist the
tale de Princess Kaguya
I have seen I've reviewed on my channel
a really gorgeously animated film
extremely different so I made a tweet
months ago saying that I saw this
incredible anime or something like that
and that it was like a a plus or
whatever ten out of ten terror in
residence is by Shinichiro Watanabe and
it's very ballsy the plot alone is very
ballsy and it has a fantastic finale
highly recommended Tokyo ghoul I have
purchased simply because of many
recommendations I have yet to see it but
I certainly will and oh my gosh one of
the last movies that I ever saw in
theaters at my childhood theater before
they tore it down the plaza 8:00 at
Chapel Hill I saw Trigon Badlands Rumble
there and there was a ton of anime fans
that's one of my earliest reviews that's
still on this channel here's a bunch of
Tsubasa stuff and xxx holic I'm not sure
if I pronounced that right but those are
my wife's and I bought those for her
because she wanted them and again I'm a
good husband I tried me vampire hunter D
and vampire hunter D bloodlust scene
vampire hunter D thought it was really
cool have not seen bloodlust yet but I
will I really want to see it because I'm
hearing it might actually be better and
that gives me tingles Venus Wars okay I
talked about this in my japanimation era
retro rewind I think this is a really
overlooked 1980s anime with gorgeous
animation I love the old style of
animation can we please go back to that
the vision of escaflowne the show and
the escaflowne movie this stuff is great
yoko kanno score is incredible it's all
my favorite aspects of it when Marnie
was there is another really underrated
Studio Ghibli film maybe their last
official movie that they 100% made
themselves without partnering with
another studio whisper of the heart I
also think is a highly underrated Studio
Ghibli movie I think this is such a
great film with a really entertaining
character who likes to explore the
library
and she goes to this antique shop and
she learned stuff about herself as a
writer it's a very inspiring movie I'll
never forget the first time I saw it the
wind rises hayao miyazaki's supposed
final film we'll see how that goes
but if it is it's definitely a high note
wolf children oh my gosh one of the
saddest animes I've ever seen not as sad
as great the fireflies but it's sad this
is a great film another memoir hosted a
film I did review it on my channel if
you'd like more info Emmy she by
Japanese ghost stories I also reviewed
this because I watched it on crunchyroll
but I haven't opened the blu-ray yet but
I picked it up because I actually really
enjoyed it it's a very different anime
they use like paper and non traditional
animation to tell the stories
Yona of the dawn is something I'm super
excited to start watching this was
another highly recommended anime and I'm
very excited to start watching it soon
and finally for the blu-rays anyway I
have all of you you Hakusho which is so
good if you've never seen you you
hakusho oh my gosh more the classic
tsunami animes from back in the day I
love it
ok so those are my anime blu-rays now
we're moving into my anime VHS a--'s
that's right ghost in the shell' and
we're done
those are my anime VHS is I used to have
the entirety of Dragon Ball Z on VHS
when I was a kid and I eventually sold
them for the DVDs and then I eventually
sold those for the blu-rays and oh man
the the pain of being a collector let's
talk about some of my anime DVDs which
is something I'm excited to do because
there's some obscure shit right here cuz
a lot of this stuff is not on blu-ray
yet and that's why I have it so let's
get started oh we got a good one here
guys this is really what I've been
waiting for like I love my anime
blu-rays but my DVDs this is a nostalgic
shit right here ad police look at that
just look at that you don't happy did
you see that anymore look at that that's
crazy that's great it looks like a 1990s
like buns of steel workout video oh my
god it's the movie whoops oh my god it's
the movie go
down I like this show it's a bit of a
guilty pleasure the movies pretty fun
actually in here we have air the
complete series another guilty pleasure
movie or show sorry that I haven't seen
in quite some time but I watched it way
WAY long time ago picked it up because
it was super cheap at this one FYE
actually here's what it was oh my god
that was backwards what am I gonna do
Armitage the third the Complete Saga uhm
how I seen all of these I know I've seen
the majority the big oh this was a lot
of fun this was on Toonami Steve Blum
did the voice of the the main guy a
little hard to find another one of those
out-of-print bandai things thanks a lot
Bandai blood the last vampire this is
one of those movies where everyone was
like you have to see this it's so good
you know like back when it came out and
it hasn't really aged amazingly but it's
it's not bad
blue gender another Toonami title excuse
me this was on Adult Swim I believe yes
now I showed you my blu-ray for blue
submarine number six I also have the DVD
because I didn't always have the blu-ray
you know wasn't always released one of
my favorite things about this is that it
does have the original Toonami TV spots
on it brain powerd whoo we're getting up
scared ow
oh shit Bubblegum Crisis Tokyo 2040 once
again we're getting obscure where we got
here--oh case closed
okay haven't opened these but I have
seen a lot of the show this is a
massively gigantic show there are so
many seasons of case closed I saw most
of what was on Adult Swim but my gosh
that's a huge show but City Hunter the
motion picture games could put that back
oh wow
one of the very few bootlegs that I own
the Cowboy Bebop perfect sessions this
is what I owned before they released the
blu-rays this was my one of my first
anime DVDs ever I bought it on eBay I
just like wow it's a good price I think
I was I don't know he's like eighteen
seventeen and I was like wow that's a
great price it's like $30 for the whole
show and it came and I was like um huh
people referred to them as the Cowboy
Bebop
well that's uh that's great spelling I
I'm pretty sure that's that's a bootleg
game on digital monsters Digimon digital
monsters did you want the movie
strangely enough is directed by Mamoru
Hosoda who later went on to direct a lot
of films I've shown you already that was
his first kind of big thing with Digimon
I'm not going to take all of them out of
here but I do have Dragon Ball season
one through five Dragon Ball is part
right there you know also the Dragon
Ball movie collection now we're getting
into some DBZ stuff here I have every
collection of all the Dragon Ball Z
movies
I'm not going to there's three of them
and I specifically however have the
Pioneer versions of the first three why
is that because that's the version I
grew up with first and I like hearing
Shawn Shimla's Goku but for those
specific three ones I like watching from
a nostalgic standpoint the pioneer
versions but still I prefer the the
Funimation dub obviously and Dragon Ball
GT the complete series because you know
it is what it is but hey thanks to
Dragon Ball super that's no longer canon
it's like an offshoot kind of alternate
universe or something it's not kin
anymore so hey Piccolo's still alive yay
Gundam Wing endless waltz oh my gosh
Gundam Wing please release Gundam Wing
on blu-ray already what are you doing
someone find out the damn rights and do
it do it uh gun sword okay gun sword is
a pretty cool show not enough people
talk about this it's not great it's kind
of cheesy but it's it's it's fun IG px
was a tsunami show immortal Grand Prix
and it was on quite a bit
Inuyasha the movie I don't know why I
have this do I have this one blu-ray - I
think this is my wife's that's that's
what it is it's my wife's
okay Arya the animation Arya Zira mom
the animation I watched this when I was
younger and that's why I bought the DVD
again haven't opened it yet can't
pronounce her name I'm kinda
a dumb person this was sent to me by a
fan I'm going to butcher this Laporte
rate the petite Cosette I did watch this
this is some trippy shit thank you for
sending this to me I really enjoyed
watching it I'm not lying I really did
that that sent me for a loop Lily Kat I
talked about this on my japanimation era
video this is a total copy off of alien
and the thing and I loved every minute
of it I do not care that is some cheesy
shit right there
memories this is a short film collection
on anime a lot of really cool stuff in
that one millennium actress won a
Satoshi Khan's films gorgeous movie
please release it on blu-ray there are a
few films of his that are not on blu-ray
like that and perfect blue and Tokyo
Godfather's at least in America why are
you sitting on this someone figure it
out just do it for me please my
neighbor's the Yamada's is a very
unknown Studio Ghibli film it was
directed by eso Takahata which I have
not yet seen but I saw it for a very
good price that Best Buy believe it or
not of all places and I picked it up
here's my giant collection of Neon
Genesis Evangelion it's a very unique
show unlike a lot of mecha anime it's
going to put that back oh my god okay
Bandai come on now give me some outlaw
star blu-ray love I need outlaw star on
blu-ray until then I'm perfectly fine
with my collection but like I want this
on an hi-def and I need the hi-def
paranoia agent another one of those eBay
things that happen where I'm like wow
good price for a paranoid agent I'm
buying that oh it's probably a bootleg
because you can just tell by the way it
feels you know it's unfortunate when
that happens but the actual sets of
paranoia agent are last time I looked
anyway absurdly expensive speaking of
perfect blue perfect blue this is a
movie that highly influenced Darren
Aronofsky to make Black Swan which is a
movie I like but there I say perfect
blue is far superior that's just my
opinion
and my opinion just went out the door
when I picked this up project ako oh man
I watched this when I was younger that's
why I bought it and a few things like
this that I have are just fun animes
that I watched when I was younger
robot carnival another short film
collection ro D read or Die saw this on
Adult Swim very very cool anime check it
out you're gonna hear me say that a lot
but what can i really say about like you
know these hundreds of titles it's cool
it's good the animation looks good what
do I say that's unique I'll try to say
something cool and fun and I hope people
like it Ronin Warriors tsunami oh my
gosh used to watch it all the time it
was one of the first ones that was on in
the lineup it was that and I think
Sailor Moon when I came home from school
oh wow this is like the only HD DVD I
have I have this on blue right now
ruined soldier oh man look at that look
at that right there that that girl right
there is like John Flickinger zalta m't
anime babe it's mine too what am I
saying oh one of my wife's that she
added to my collection the rurouni
kenshin show obviously a bootleg it's
just one of those things where you buy
it and it gets sent to you and you're
like yeah I'm so excited to get this and
oh my god this is like taking five weeks
to get here oh it's from Malaysia I
understand everything now shattered
Angels one of my wife shows haven't seen
it salty ray another show that I started
watching and would like to finish got
the DVD because it was on sale sprig in'
this is one of those like you know one
of the best animated films ever you must
see it and you're watching like that was
pretty good alright it wasn't great
steam boy this is a beautifully animated
movie not the greatest film but it's
gorgeous to look at talking-head this is
a very strange Mamoru Oshii film its
live-action mostly but there is some
animation involved with it it's uh man
that's one of the weirdest movies I've
ever seen actually and that's saying
something for Mamoru Oshii film because
he's made some weird ones and that one
takes the cake next we have some more of
my wife's stuff Tenchi universe
Tenshi the movie and tenshi ryo-ohki
yeah I think I have another one even
yeah Tenchi Muyo GXP my wife's a big
Tenchi fan I watched Tenchi universe on
Toonami but I haven't seen the offshoot
shows they were 11 I talked about this
in my japanimation era video I think
this is a super under looked under
looked I've been talking about movies
for a while haven't I
I combined overlooked and underrated is
the super underrated movie and it's also
overlooked here's a big-ass collection
Trigun yet another show that is not on
Blu right what are you doing people what
are you doing your acai yacht sura
Mamoru Oshii films uh helps to have seen
the show because if you just watch those
without seeing the show you're just sort
of jumping into the pond and you don't
know what's going on
lucio and torah I bought this because I
want to see it have not seen it yet oh
my god here we go
this is super duper silly fanservice II
Van dread oh my goodness uh yeah
witch hunter Robin pretty cool show
check it out sometime
and finally Wolf's reign
this actually was just announced it's
going to be on blu-ray in February again
I'm not sure what I'm going to post this
video so if I'm if the timeline of me
saying that is weird when I post this
but I did pre-order it because it's a
gorgeous show yoko kanno has amazing
music for it
that is my anime collection my blu-rays
and my DVDs I really appreciate you guys
watching I wanted to share that with you
at some point in the future I might make
another one because just like with my
regular blu-rays the collection grows
and it grows and grows I am done making
blu-ray updates though I think for
movies because it's just too massive and
I've made enough to the point where you
guys kind of can see the kind of stuff I
own with anime though maybe in a couple
years I'll make another one I really
appreciate you guys watching thank you
so much look forward to a few specific
anime things I'm doing this year as I
said I'm doing a full in-depth analysis
of angels egg Mario she's 1985 film see
it it is worth it and I'm also doing
ghost in the shell' reviews before
new ghosts Michelle movie as well ghost
Michelle one two and solid state society
guys thank you once again for watching
and if you liked this you can click
right here and get stuck the nice
[Applause]
[Music]